but yeah junjito that anime just watch
it I haven't I've watched this anything
I've watched a few episodes yes which
ones did you watch I think the first
couple of ones I watched all of them why
holy [__] when I was um getting ready
for the cyclathon I was like what's
something that I can kind of like stop
watching at any point and not feel like
I need to like like excuse like some
shows it's like I hate it if I have to
stop it halfway right yeah because I'm
like man I just want to keep watching it
I just want to keep watching I wanna if
I stop where I am right now I'm gonna
have to backtrack like five minutes to
remember where I was yeah it was
normally the episode's end and they
normally kind of episodic yeah yeah it's
like you know so I was I was just
watching it and I was like holy [__]
none of these are good
yeah can we just appreciate this moment
where the boys have watched something
that I haven't watched but I guess the
reason there because you're a [__]
smart yeah yeah you're too busy watching
19 Easter guys so so the reason I
haven't watched it is because I believe
this is another adaptation that's
different from the ginger YouTube
collection yeah that aired like five
years ago
is this also called the junji Ito
collection I believe no no it's called
the the tales of the Macabre
yeah it's on it's on Netflix so like
nobody nobody [__] said anything
about this yeah
um you you it wasn't in any of your
videos It Wasn't that's what I normally
find out about what's going on in anime
is watching your videos and so like I
remember I think we were at Sumo and
Felix just goes oh have you been
watching this new YouTube thing and I
was like what the [__] this is a new
dude yeah I didn't even know Felix was
the one at all yeah and no one's
speaking about it he's like yeah I just
saw it on Netflix and I was like oh okay
so I watched it and I was wondering why
no one's speaking about it yeah oh my
God
yeah I I think and I I don't say this
lightly I have never seen it's been
years since I've watched an anime this
bad yeah it it is so dog [__] yeah this
is just further proves this and the
junior collection which I sat through
the entirety of yeah because I hate
myself like just like solid evidence you
cannot adapt jujito stuff yeah I think
jinjito is unadaptable yeah I yeah I I
have you read any of his manga no do
yourself a favor like a nice eye cleanse
watching this I feel like how like
seeing the stories portrayed in that
light can never I don't think I can ever
see them as funny ever again I know
sorry not scary because to me
70 of them were funny the other 30 were
just boring yeah yeah like they open up
with this holy [__] this most god-awful
episode of anime I've ever watched in my
life you watch the first episode right
yes don't be like The Addams Family
basically yeah oh Imagine The Adams
Family that's a weak story in the
morning
and for some reason they put that as the
first episode yeah so like everyone
who's watching this has to sit through
this garbage episode well they did that
with the junjito collection as well they
opened up with like the kid who like
curses everyone yeah and I'm like this
is a [__] story like why would you open
up with this so then you you [__] you
open up this anime right and holy [__]
you get greeted with the the intro song
it's like it's like it's like they were
paying someone to miss because the
opening song is a [__] like screamo
metal song yeah how is that horror how
does that how does that at all get me in
the mood for horror like all of jujitos
things like you know climactic
you have like this guy it's like oh no
we're gonna visit my family grave and
then he goes
get ready for the anime yeah and then
you just start the stupid Adams Family
[__] and it's not even remotely scary
it's just [__] weird and it's been
like I don't know as a song it's fine
but just don't it was the worst mix and
match it makes your [__] sense and
then like I was waiting for the iconic
episodes or like the iconic stories yeah
so one of the most most iconic episodes
which uh you you know told me off camera
was uh the one with the balloon heads
yeah that [__] was so funny and that is
like normally looked at as one of his
you know that's a fan favorite story you
know one of one of one of uh the short
stories that people very much like and
very much portrays the gingito style and
I remember telling that to Connor he was
like I found it [__] hilarious throw
in this because in the show they're like
well honey it looks like everybody
outside is being turned into balloons
and he's like well I'm off to
he just walks outside and [__] dies
even though he just made an observation
that there were murderous balloons
outside that's that's what you have to
understand about GG kind of though like
no one I think the person who takes
jinji Ito Stories the least serious is
junjito himself oh which is why like I I
like I don't know if they just
misunderstood if it was meant to be
because like in the same [__] balloon
thing the whole twist at the end is like
the girl the main girl who is following
right she so everyone outside has been
for some reason has been turned into
murderous balloons and when you die you
also turn into a murderous polarity yeah
I there is no more context that is it
yeah and they just they like grab you by
it there they have like nooses attached
to the bottom of the balloons and they
just go and hang you yeah I imagine it's
terrifying in the market in the anime
it's [__] it's always falling in the
morning yeah it's it's like his his
stuff isn't terrifying it just is just
unsettling yeah a 99 of that is just to
do with his art because right right his
art is in [__] incredible right to
the point where if you don't portray
I've seen the art looks amazing yeah
yeah it's his art just evokes the best
way I can describe it is that it's it
just evokes emotions yeah right and
unless you translate those emotions like
his like singular pen scratches that he
does the way he Shades everything there
is no way to translate this feel this
still like painting that he's basically
made into like an animated form in my
opinion yeah because a lot of a lot of
his uh a lot of his stories uh on paper
are pretty ridiculous because they are
they're all like really absurd which is
why it was kind of it was kind of fun to
watch yeah because then when it was
funny it was quite funny yeah like uh
the ending of the balloon one to spoil
it if you care
um there's like that's like a 10-page
shorts yeah this girl is like trapped in
because they you know the The Genius of
this world figured out if you just don't
leave the house you can't die yeah
obviously need to get food anyway her
like Dead Brother is like knocking on
the window being like hey I'm out I'm
outside she's like oh [__] for real
opens the door obviously it's a [__]
dead body balloon but how is the body
even [__] talking it's so [__]
dumb there was one story that I kind of
liked yeah the premise a lot and they
just kind of [__] it up right at the
end which one uh the tomb Town one
sounds like Toontown but in my British
accent it's too Hometown Toontown as
they called it it's where when people
die in this town they immediately like
uh you can't touch the bodies they just
turn into gravestones yeah on the spot
oh yes yes and it was kind of a really
cool concept because we you know we
agreed to this this idea and you're you
know the main character runs over a girl
yeah and then he's with his sister and
like oh my god well we should do
something he's like no put him put her
in the [__] trunk or barrier like oh
okay geez and then they go into this
town they're just [__] gravestones
everywhere and oh it's so [__] so
[__] and then they go to this house to
meet their friend and turns out their
friend they just run over her sister and
then they're like oh where's our
sister's like I don't know right sister
we don't know and then eventually they
throw her in the well and it turns into
the shitty CGI dragon that looks
horrible like ass and it's so [__]
stupid oh it's so dumb every time like a
new jinjito anime adaptation comes out
there's like one percent of my brain
that's like this is the one this is the
one that's gonna change it and every
single [__] time it's just gotten
worse and worse like I thought the Go
movie was bad when I first watched that
I was gonna say I think yo is the only
decent I think yeah after the junjito
collection and this new one I think now
it makes okay it made those it was so
bad it makes you look like I'm gonna
defend yo because not this it's not
really know that uh so it's one of the
long stories but it's one of the long
stories got adapted into a movie like no
no no animated by Studio you photable
what studio animated a ginger YouTube
adaptation and it's the best uh animated
adaptation he's ever gotten and probably
ever will get
um but I would say that the manga itself
had some like incredible body horror and
um that was like one of the standouts
about it you put that on in an animated
form and it's it's not scary I'm gonna
say that it's not scary but holy [__] it
was so much fun it was so funny so the
entire concept of go is basically fish
start invading lands right and how do we
how did they invade land uh there are
sharks and fish and they grow robot legs
yeah they're mechanical legs underneath
I think I've seen the stills of this
yeah yeah you've probably seen the still
of like the shark with the mechanical
legs entering the room yeah yeah that's
a really famous shot yeah so they they
just invade the land and uh I guess fish
have decided to take the Earth back
because they are the ones who rule the
earth now yeah and it's just and it's
just a whole movie about fish
terrorizing people on land with
mechanical legs
um some scientists tried to do some wild
experiments and it goes wrong
and you know it's just tying your brain
off popcorn fun I had a good [__]
time watching that it was like watching
a beach you should [__] watch that
yeah was it was it scary no was it
hilarious yes there was one that was
kind of scary a little bit problem with
the um where they peel the skin off
oh that one I can't remember what that
was kind of fun that was kind of well
[__] yeah yeah because like the
they find out from some of course it's
always an archaeological site where they
move somebody and then turns out that
she just has like 26 layers of skin yeah
and then she like ages or something like
it's like one for every age yeah yeah
and then her mom is like [__]
obsessed with her being like young again
so she starts tearing off her daughter's
face yeah
um but it was really funny in the anime
for like the first half and then it
actually got scary yeah that's one of my
favorite stories of his as well but
again a lot of his is just to do with
his art and the way he sets the tone of
his stories uh because like the balloon
one it's on paper it's just ridiculous
and even like the skin one as well oh my
God this keeps reminding me the other
[__] stories one of the stories was
like hey um You probably watched this
one too it's right like hey um my
brother's making too much noise
so we're gonna hire a carpenter to make
my room soundproof yeah yeah and then
the guy comes in he's like yeah of
course I can make soundproof so he
builds four rooms inside of a room and
one of them is just a tiny tiny ass Cub
he's like there you go it's soundproof
and then his brother just goes between
the walls just menacing him yeah and
that's it and then he like lays like
[__] oil and grease in it to trap him
and it's like what the [__] is this like
this no no you know what takes the cake
sorry I'm running an even another one
okay there's another story all these
sound [__] stupid yeah I'll explain
them did you see the ice cream one no I
don't think so have you seen this one
yes
this is snoring it opens up and this is
a guy who drives an ice cream truck and
he's like hey kids in the neighborhood
who wants some ice cream yeah and then
that's like no I call him I guess ice
cream I call him go in the ice cream
truck and they're like all the other
kids are in the ice cream truck is like
ah fine go in the ice cream truck okay
goes in the ice cream truck this [__]
ice cream truck goes around the corner
with like the worst goddamn CGI I've
ever seen in your life it was terrible
anyway so it comes out and then kid
comes back and he's like kind of
miserable and he's like I don't know I
don't want to do anything I just want to
go to the ice cream truck again so he
goes in the ice cream truck again and
then the kid comes back and comes up
with his friend his friend starts
turning in a [__] ice cream and then
he he starts licking his friend and then
it turns out that like everyone in this
truck is just old kids that turned into
ice cream and then you turn into ice
cream when you lick the kid ice cream
and then it was just like what is this
[__] and this dad's kid turns into an
ice scream he's like no and she's like
what is this [__] I respect it like to
the point where it's like I feel this is
just like junji ito's like personal
challenge yeah to like look at something
in the real world like he'll look at a
chair and be like I can make a horse I
like that he never tries to [__]
explain his horror no no that's that's
the other thing yeah the guy driving the
ice cream truck what's his deal yeah he
knows it's [__] no nothing else yeah
the other one told me is at the famous
person was good though Tommy is really
[__] good I thought it wasn't good in
the show really I didn't get it in the
show you didn't get it I didn't get it
what do you mean I didn't really under
so she was just like cursed like her
face or some [__] it was [__] weird
yeah well what's the point of this [__]
well try try to decipher the the
intricacies of a junior is hard that's
the thing it's not about it's not about
what it's about because most of it is
unexplained and it's made that way
because as soon as you explain something
it just becomes less scary yeah it's
just opens itself I agree yeah as soon
as you bring the answers so why one of
the his most famous works is Uzumaki
which that was that was his thing where
he I guess he tried to make something
horrific around this really abstract
concept spirals yeah so for some reason
spirals just start becoming cursed right
to the point where everything turns into
space everything turns into a spiral
like we don't go back to Monkey we go
back to spiral you know that sounds
great yeah I mean you've probably seen
the like one of the most famous shots
from Uzumaki is this shot of like it's
inside like a big like uh shallow uh
Barrel yeah and like that they've it
just appears in the living room one day
and the daughter and the mama like what
the [__] is this what the [__] is this
barrel and they open it up and it's the
husband that's been like wrapped around
inside oh my God just like completely
de-skinned and everything and it's
[__] horrific and I'm just like yo
how how scary can spirals be how
obviously that pattern you're like yeah
[__] is [__] and then you know you
where you find out like people start
avoiding Spirals and you're like that
shouldn't be too hard and then you
realize that your inner ear has like a
spiral in it and it's just like
somebody's like wild [__] ideas where
it's like bird box but you can't see the
spiders
um and then it just becomes like really
good kind of like Cosmic lovecraftian
horror because he never explains what's
up with the spirals you know you never
get an explanation even in yo they never
explain it yeah why are the fish coming
to terrorize us I
I think just voice acting these kind of
stuff just hurts it I don't know why
yeah yeah I think yeah in a weird way
kind of takes the heavy lifting that you
your brain might be doing for you to
make it scarier yeah and puts it on
someone else and you're talking like
listen to them again I think like the
biggest advantage of jinjito stories is
just like it it uses its like quietness
to its Advantage so the moment you start
adding anything like voice acting or
music or sound effects it just feels
tacky yeah and I don't know why it could
be it could honestly be the most well
animated thing yeah the moment you start
to hear stuff like that I feel it just
takes away from the subtlety of it like
super popular in Japan does people
really want to know he's because I'd say
Infamous because I told some people I'm
like oh you've seen Juju they're like
who I feel like if you like manga you'll
know him but like he's not like a
household name or anything like that I
feel like if you just like horror as
well because I I I talk to some people
who have like are not into like the
anime sphere at all I talked to someone
who was just like what the [__] is
Attack on Titan and somehow he had read
a gingito work just because he was like
super into horror yeah right yeah so
I'll get him into anime yes yeah yeah
yeah start off with horror with his
Blair Witch and which was great because
I he was like he was like I'm really
into lovecraftian Aura but I've read
into YouTube stuff is there anything
else you could recommend and I was like
oh boy do I have something called uh do
I have something for you called made in
Abyss which I think is the best you know
uh lovecraftian Horror in anime right
now it's not ever you know yeah I didn't
start I don't know if it always started
off that way but especially made in the
best season two it's just gotten like
[__] movies
holy [__] but like it's what blows my
mind about meeting the best is that it's
just getting harder and harder to
recommend now not because it's getting
far yeah not because it's getting worse
but it's getting progressively more and
more weird in a way that I can't really
convey with words you know it's really
difficult to explain season two yeah
yeah season two is a weird one like it
was great but it was also like what the
[__] did I watch like what am I watching
so many times I have to backtrack being
like hold on I need to hear that
explanation yeah yeah yeah and you know
that's that's what I personally I love
the direction I made in this two is
going where it just gives me this like
creepy it it [__] with you it [__]
with your emotions in a way that few
pieces of media can because you can't
really describe how it goes about doing
that all it does all you know is that it
is doing something really weird and
making you feel really uncomfortable and
weird things and you can't really
explain why it's doing that she's in two
maybe give up on the fact that they'll
be a good ending
[Music]
maybe there's a chance that it could be
positive but the moment I saw meaty in
season one I was like oh no no no no
this is gonna be bad I think this is
really good though if you haven't
watched it watch made in Abyss um it is
[__] weird yeah